Today, I’m going to tell you a little story
about balls.
Hey shady ballers, Jules here for Dnews.
If you’ve ever been to Los Angeles, you
may have seen a ton of little plastic balls
floating on top of their water reservoirs.
There are millions of them!
So many that from far away, they look more
like a blacktop than a gigantic, wet, Chuck
E Cheese ball pit.
But before diving in face first, consider
that these balls actually serve a very important
purpose.
Reservoirs, like the ones in Los Angeles store
the city’s drinkable and potable water.
But Federal law says that they can’t just
leave this water exposed to the open air.
When the EPA enacted this mandate in 2006,
it was responding to an outbreak of cryptosporidiosis
[crypto-spor-idy-osis], a stomach illness
contracted from drinking contaminated water,
namely from reservoirs.
But Crypto-whatever is not the only side effect
of exposed reservoirs.
Uncovered water can be pooped in by birds,
or just get dirty from dust and dirt settling
on top.
In the aftermath of 9/11, a lot of people
were concerned that open reservoirs would
be targeted by terrorists - like the enemy
would fly by on a plane and drop in toxic
chemicals, infecting entire populations.
But Batman-based terror attacks aside, the
biggest concern when it came to exposed drinking
water, at least for LA County, was a chemical
reaction that occurs when the water interacts
with sunlight.
LA’s reservoirs contain a small amount of
chlorine as a disinfectant.
In direct sunlight, when chlorine combines
with a natural element found in groundwater,
bromide, it creates a chemical called “bromate”.
Bromate sucks to ingest, and can cause stomach
pain, nausea, and in high doses, serious damage
to the kidneys and nervous system.
Sunlight can also lead to algae growth, which
isn’t harmful in itself.
But when algae breaks down and the organic
components mix with chlorine, it creates byproducts,
which have been associated with birth defects
and even certain cancers.
So, LA county needed to cover up their reservoirs.
And they considered a few ways of doing it.
The most logical solutions were to build a
huge roof, or use a massive tarp.
But these alternatives were going to be really
expensive.
Like, $300 million dollars expensive.
That’s like three quarters of the average
cost to launch a damn space shuttle.
So instead, LA County went with “shade balls”.
The idea was pretty simple: 96 million 4-inch
diameter plastic balls would float on the
reservoir, preventing evaporation and protecting
the water from harmful airborne pollutants23.
The balls were also coated with a black carbon
colorant that repels ultraviolet light, which
can cause plastics and other materials to
degrade.
This chemical coating is intended to protect
them for up to 25 years.
Thankfully, shade balls are also economical.
Each ball costs just 36 cents, representing
a total savings of roughly $250 million dollars
for LA County.
This is all fairly new.
In fact, LA is the first county to use shade
balls for this purpose.
But they’re getting a lot of attention,
especially as a way to mitigate the effects
of this never-ending drought.
The Los Angeles Reservoir’s shade balls
are expected to prevent roughly 300 million
gallons of water from evaporating every year.
The only downside?
The balls jokes.
So what do you think?
Could shade balls be the future of environmental
protection?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe to DNews
for more videos every single day.